Hey, YouTube. It's BTS Week
at "The Tonight Show."
And every day,
we're bringing you
an amazing new performance
from the group.
Here now to perform
the hit song "Black Swan,"
from their 2020 EP
"Map of the Soul: 7,"
BTS.
Do your thang
Do your thang with me now
What's my thang?
What's my thang? Tell me now
Tell me now
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah
Heart stops beating anymore
when listening to music
Tryna pull up
It's like the time stops
Oh, that would be my first death
I've been always afraid of
If it couldn't make me cry
anymore
If it couldn't make my heart
tremble anymore
Maybe I would die once like this
But what if that moment's
right now, right now
Heart beating slowly in my ears
Bump, bump, bump
Trying to get out,
but in my throat
Jump, jump, jump
No song can touch my heart
I shout, no sound comes out
The sea silencing all the lights
Yeah, yeah, yeah
Hold me back again, already lost
I can't hear any sound
Yeah, yeah, yeah
Killin' me now, killin' me now
Do you hear me? Yeah
Slowly sinking like
I'm possessed
Nah, nah, nah
I struggle but hit the bottom
Nah, nah
Every moment becomes eternal
Yeah, yeah, yeah
Feelin' me now, feelin' me now
Do you hear me? Yeah
Do your thang
Do your thang with me now
What's my thang
What's my thang? Tell me now
Tell me now
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah
Deeper
Yeah, I think I'm goin' deeper
I lose my focus again and again
Let me go, I don't like it
I'd rather go myself
I'll dive into it
When I hit the deepest bottom
I saw myself
I opened my eyes slowly
Here's my studio
Even if the heavy waves hit me
in the dark
I'll never be dragged down again
Inside, I saw myself
Myself
Heart beating fast in my ears
Bump, bump, bump
Open my eyes and to my forest
Jump, jump, jump
Nothing can swallow me
I shout with all my strength
The sea silencing all the lights
Yeah, yeah, yeah
Hold me back again, already lost
I can't hear any sound
Yeah, yeah, yeah
Killin' me now, killin' me now
Do you hear me? Yeah
Slowly sinking
like I'm possessed
Nah, nah, nah
I struggle but hit the bottom
Nah, nah
Every moment becomes eternal
Yeah, yeah, yeah
Feelin' me now, feelin' me now
Do you hear me? Yeah
Do your thang
Do your thang with me now
What's my thang?
What's my thang? Tell me now
Tell me now
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah